you dare enter this [ __ ] house
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] boffin please Tommy ate and
stars last year you know my body's
rejecting all these your body's
rejecting your pockets don't reject my
face red [ __ ] cat delicious you but
I'd rather trust grip than [ __ ]
chicken no yeah least I could tell it
that's the death even more disgusting
they slice those thin strips off a cat
that I [ __ ] you're crazy
yeah I get the Pad Thai shrimp good
that's how you don't touch my Triple A
later I buy it a nice place yeah you
wouldn't eat shrimp on a Thai place is
going it yeah an intensified chicken
yeah you see learn how to deal with
people
it's just you can't get out of your way
you get the worst food just want
principle and we've got your assistant
or whatever encourages you everyone lies
yeah
[Music]
then you get chicken with no stripper -
you don't even know if it's chicken
you know if this change this piece of
white people to paint in it that could
be any [ __ ] animal that could be any
[ __ ] at all you don't know that you
never thought about that way at least
with shrimp I got identified - shrimp
get the big prawns together by
[Music]
beautiful box oh [ __ ] [ __ ] Thursday
night [ __ ] don't we drop the stars five
stars left 20 minutes I got the six
stars left
he's eating four [ __ ] stars to my
ballsack get your really [ __ ] stall
until he kills it wait I do that side
chicken you'll know if it's chicken
that's why I stopped eating that [ __ ]
about Chinese food I never went back to
that delight by your house cuz you don't
can't top the chicken just move and
white meat think you get that from my
yeah anyways them
[Music]
you
what's happened you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here Wednesday night priest
Church the Savage is back we got tons of
weed leaves on his took him 20 minutes
to eat five [ __ ] stars he's trying to
tell me he took guys trust me there's a
scam he made Fugazi stars he can't even
finish him here
two stars he's got drink two gallons of
water his face is red
he's about the bar is I'm saying you
can't [ __ ] a bullshitter preacher
chore what's happening now how you don't
[ __ ] said uncle Joey loves you
[ __ ] is a beautiful night to be
alive we got a great podcast as usual
least doing 2002 cover me for Lent the
anti left so we're getting that party
started if you're a teen hang on now I
can't have no youngsters on here
watching this type of [ __ ] we might even
do a hit asset tonight I'm feeling perky
tonight [ __ ] you know I'm saying the
stars are out the birds are singing
it's your type of night [ __ ]
[Music]
we got some beautiful reefer Ross dude
gave me last night the score oh [ __ ]
it's like Gorilla Glue meets King Kong
I am Godzilla you are Japan [ __ ] I'm
saying it's that type of night Kyle
looking late look at this face look so
he tell me you saw me funny then start
looking eat this last one go ahead
you got two more anyway hold on you got
that one from the floor we got a queen
[ __ ] shoe arrested yeah let me see if
you wait ten stars chew on a guy how
long
don't worry about ain't nobody called me
okay let's look at it look at this
[ __ ] night nag a little a little he
poses no but it's [ __ ] [ __ ] make it
appear as me all right what's happened
you beautiful [ __ ]
I guess I'm here alone with you he's got
to go put the pieces [ __ ] together
[Music]
I'm back they had to smoke and your
smoking was smoking it's a good night
you know I'm saying it's always a good
[ __ ] at night when we're together on a
Wednesday I'm like going out on
Wednesdays although specially chosen
town I'm on my business I hit and run
with you [ __ ] up is why cuz I love you
I don't want to do a show on Wednesday
anyway I won't do a show on Thursday I'm
dying to score Saturday and I'm good for
the [ __ ] week Sunday we're releasing
a special podcast for you [ __ ]
Monday we got a podcast then that's over
for the [ __ ] month I'm going to New
York City to enjoy myself like a [ __ ]
I'm saying can I have a little enjoyment
now be at Nyack New York at 11 alive up
there by the old [ __ ] Cuckoo's
Nest and that's it and that's that
that's the way we do it here
no drama nobody gets their feelings hurt
a little pyromania bro we're gonna drop
some [ __ ] on you tonight and all you
needs a smoke bomb or cherry bomb yeah
and that's it here jim Florentine a
little music guy [ __ ] great come in I
was thinking about the first time I met
him in Davie Florida that's the first
time I met funny Uncle funny's we call
headlined on a Wednesday and I never saw
him again
I went to open up for Marsha Warfield
and you stayed to do open up for
somebody I went to West Palm Beach
something crazy
yeah so we co-headlined Wednesday told
me live them we talking and that's it
you thirsty
[Music]
I get every one of those on vinyl
I got Waller you have to you have to you
have to [ __ ] have everything I'm
vital young saying you got a switch in
my rap I'm trying I'm trying it's rough
it's rough you know people like to get
to out in the vinyl back I had a great
collection I used to rob shop write and
tell me you haven't knew I figured out
when I was in high school they they got
how you saw it going the daytime and
take the album's I wanted and I put them
in the rack with a fence hit so at nine
o'clock they will close that that side
of shop life where the liquor was that a
little album thing so we just come over
with my cart sticking my hand through
the [ __ ] thing pick up the album's I
wanted and put them through the fence
and then I would put them under the car
I'd walk up to the [ __ ] dang empty my
groceries but I'd still have the cart
with the album's in the bottle by the
time I put the groceries back on it's
11:30 at night there's no security is
nobody there was 80 [ __ ] one I would
just walk out of there with the [ __ ]
out and I built a huge out collect knife
and I would take the arms out and put
them all up around the [ __ ] a little
bit that's what you did nice to go out
to route 17 in Paramus out that way had
a place like that Crazy Eddie Crazy
Eddie had a store that had out same
thing there that's where I got diver
down I want to name got walk down there
with six albums I would pay for one and
leave the other ones down below the
calendar was high so when you walked up
to the count it was here right so you
would walk up to the counter with the
six hours but you would only put one on
the counter and keep the other five on
the floor when you rang it up and they
give you the bag you had to do a Dipper
ooh pick up the album and then turn your
wrist around and cover the album's with
the album that you bought and we
I robbed half of New Jersey Boys the end
like an 81 in North Bergen on Colley
Avenue we would go down there we've gone
I still remember what the movie was on
HBO that month you ready the hot movies
I need to be over the thief February of
82 was the thief Raging Bull and
Hollywood nights and we would get home
at night see that was coming on at 1:00
and we [ __ ] walk the shop right we'd
walk the tunnel yeah let's like this to
Hill we've walked it down the Avenue get
milk ice cream wheat germ bananas
Hershey syrup and [ __ ] there was no coke
cut counties in those days and we would
just go home and make ice cream shakes
smoke dope and watch movies till 6:00
good old days no they have like the top
10 hours and then they would have like a
like they would have Harris Smith maybe
like Toys in the Attic and like night in
the ruts and that was it they didn't
have every out but whatever they had
like to use I clipped what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yes
[ __ ] yeah I still remember getting
circus and reading it officially that
Ozzy had left Sabbath like I still
remember [ __ ] running to the
magazines toilets that house he leaves
Sabbath and like crying on burning
lighter like it's over can you still get
that do you think we could find that on
eBay
yeah somebody brought me this to his
show cuz they spoke about how now you
read the internet but when I was growing
up it was circus Magazine dog that was
it Rolling Stone was okay but
yeah Romans don't didn't like No
we'll be back in ten minutes youtube.com
/ c / Joey Diaz please I have to find
you
Jimmy florentine the man and uncle Joey
my man from mental midgets we'll be back
[ __ ]